the un uh relief agency um said that
they have fired some of their staff
after Israel has accused them of being
involved in the Hamas what is the White
House thinking on this I know the state
department has has said that they're
suspending a temporarily are there other
steps the US is conern yeah we have
suspended any uh outlying um um or yet
to be allocated uh funds for uh for unra
the UN relief and works agency um
pending the results of this
investigation obviously going to watch
this very closely we welcome uh the UN
Secretary General and the commissioner
general of lra uh their comments today
calling for a full investigation uh as
secretary blinkin made clear in his call
with the Secretary General yesterday we
expect that that will be a complete and
thorough and transparent investigation
we all want to see that it's good for
everybody uh and that uh those who are
uh who are who who should be uh are
properly held accountable for that and
as as you saw um the UN said even
including the potential for a criminal
prosecution this step Sim simultaneously
taken during the war in g s a wrong
message this this is there is a war
against the Palestinian people this
decision is incorrect and should be
stopped immediately we urge all these do
all these countries to repay the Ona
because it's a humanitarian issue it it
has been taken in a long time and we
hope that they will come back soon to
understand that the need of the the
people in Gaza and everywhere is a
necessity for continuing living on this
Earth no nobody will follow what America
is saying there are three four countries
follow America everywhere in the
security C Council or in the icg or
whatever we hope that this policy would
end they tried it hundreds of times they
failed they should understand they
should understand very well that they
have to change their policies in in case
they wanted peace and Security in the
Middle East you have seen what's going
on here in Palestine and Lebanon in
Syria in Yemen in Iraq and everywhere
it's a regional or almost a regional war
in the whole area and they should
understand very well that the starting
point of ending this war is establishing
a Palestinian State the refugee problem
is very important the satisfaction of
the Palestinian people is very important
and this is the starting point otherwise
continuous wars in the region and
everybody will pay a heavy price there
is a decision has been taken in laigh in
alh that we will follow it up in
according to the security Council we
will follow it follow it up in the
security Council and you know we have
rights unless the Israelis understand
that we have rights and we will follow
them in every Court in the world ICC icj
in the security Council in the general
assembly at the UNESCO this is this is
the way we are going to continue because
these are our rights and we have the
majority of the world standing by us and
we hope that this time the am the
Americans and the British would
understand that without establishing a
Palestina State nobody will be safe in
the
area this is the starting point for Abu
Mazin since day one he said there should
be an end of the war then we are ready
to talk about every single issue without
ending the war all these pretexts here
or there are not going to lead
anywhere